[Musique]
10 années se sont écoulées depuis la
tragédie de lac-mégantique une décennie
longue mais courte à la fois pour la
population endeuillée on veut que tout
l'été soit doux les gens n'ont pas
nécessairement le goût de se replonger
dans les émotions d'il y a 10 ans ce
qu'ils veulent c'est de qu'on mette en
lumière le chemin parcourue c'est plus
ça qui fait du sens 10 ans plus tard qui
aimerait se dire et pour mettre en
lumière ce chemin parcouru l'équipe de
proximité est là une fois de plus il y
avait une volonté pas juste l'outil le
temps de la commémoration autour du 6
juillet le métier un été réconfort je
suis fier de vous dire que notre équipe
de proximité et si on veut lancer
officiellement parce créer rapidement
après la tragédie l'équipe s'est étalée
aux organismes déjà existants
l'objectif être sur le terrain au
quotidien pour un maximum de gens
la beauté de la chose de l'équipe de
proximité qu'on a été très chanceux ça a
été d'avoir cette confiance là qu'on
nous a accordé on parle d'une page
blanche mais on a des données probantes
qui nous dirigent au fil des ans des
études permettent de cibler qui va bien
et moins bien chaque fois un même
constat s'impose il faut interpeller les
citoyens les mettre en action ça fait
partie du processus de résilience le
sentiment de contribution à sa
communauté ça construit beaucoup il y a
donc eu ces nombreuses initiatives par
et pour la population
à première vue on se demande c'est quoi
le lien mais je vous parlerai des
greaters par exemple que c'est un groupe
de citoyens pour se réapproprier leur
territoire l'amour de la place d'eau
élevée on va leur donner l'occasion de
le raconter à d'autres des petits pas
tous très importants
et ça se poursuit avec l'organisation
entre autres de cette activité
d'improvisation cet été je pense que si
on parle d'une communauté en mouvement
une communauté vivante comme les autres
avec Co et ses bas c'est tout à fait ce
que toutes les communautés vives
d'ailleurs mais avec une histoire
différente la nôtre mais il y a eu la
tragédie de la mégantique une histoire
avec de nouveaux chapitres parmi les
beaux cet espace dédié à la jeunesse
et puis
ce que ça évolue dans ce sens là aussi
je pense c'est important que les jeunes
continuent de prendre part aussi à dire
leurs mots sur qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
réellement ici dans dans la ville
leur donner de nouveaux lieux de
rencontre et favoriser un esprit de
communauté et l'une des clés selon
Steven c'est le plus jeune que je vois
présentement les 12 ans il y avait deux
ans qui a s’était arrivé donc eux ça
allo c'est comme un livre d'histoire que
qu'on va d'un cours c'est un peu comme
ça pour eux entendre parler de ça par
leur famille leurs proches leur ami mais
concrètement ils ont pas vu l'ancien
centre-ville ils ont pas vu comment
c'était avant
se souvient mais sur le terrain on
insiste la population regarde aussi vers
l'avant on se raconte des choses qu'on
fait et pas et on est passé à travers ça
il y en avait des choses à mais c'est à
traverser mais c'est ça qui est le plus
réconfortant et encourageant ici
Marie-Ève Laca Radio-Canada la clinique